Joseph in Joseph says, Hey David, why will
stupid Democrats like Bernie and Warren insist
on weakening our military? This is one of
those questions that really requires a little
bit of historical context to understand. And
the historical context is that going back
decades now, there has been an attempt from
the right to feminize the left. And, uh, what
we're really talking about is the feminization
of democratic male candidates. If you look
at 2004, uh, and you look at John Kerry, John
Kerry was a military veteran. The right loves
to talk about so-called war heroes. We can
debate whether somebody who served in the
military is or isn't a war hero by default.
Reasonable people can argue about that is
merely serving your country. An act of heroism
does it depending on what you, whatever, right?
The conversation doesn't matter by the definition
that the right used. John Kerry was a war
hero. Uh, and yet they feminized him. They
talked about him speaking French. They talked
about him, you know, being European in whatever
ways they minimized his, uh, military credentials.
The Swift boat veterans, uh, came out and
attacked, carry around his claims regarding
military service. And this is all part of
this, uh, movement that exists to feminize
the left as being afraid of war, as being
afraid of guns, as shying away irrationally
from violence. So that's where you get questions
like this. Why will Democrats weaken our military?
And of course, the truth is that our military
is so over-funded. It is so many orders of
magnitude inflated beyond what it needs to
be to still be the strongest and biggest military
in the world.
That anyone who says, you know what, I'm concerned
about how much we're spending on the military.
I'm concerned about the foreign policy, the
moral, the legal, the ethical implications
of how far the tentacles of our military spread.
They are accused like what we are seeing here
of wanting to weaken our military when the
truth is that, uh, even significant cuts to
the military would not weaken the military.
The U S would be more than able to protect
itself from any kind of attack. But there's
another element that I want to talk about
here. Uh, there's this idea that a democratic
president like Bernie or Warren, the right
likes to push this. If push came to shove
and the correct decision was a military engagement,
they simply wouldn't do it. They paint a picture
of potential democratic presidents as people
who the U S would be under attack domestically.
One of our allies of base whatever.
And the military would come to president Bernie
Sanders or Elizabeth Warren. They say, Madam
president, mr president, we're under attack.
We've got to do something. And Bernier Warren
would sit back and say, no, we're not going
to do anything. We will allow ourselves to
simply be attacked and people to be killed.
This is not how things work. I know that with
Donald Trump who operates unilaterally going
completely against the recommendations of
the Pentagon and the state department and
whoever it seems as though that's something
that presidents typically do. The reality
is that both Bernie Sanders and Elizabeth
Warren have made no indication that they are
a pacifists, a priori, and they have made
it abundantly clear that if they were president,
when military advisers come to them and they
explain the situation on the ground, they
would basically follow the advice of their
generals as Donald Trump likes to say. So
the question is problematic.
At its core, it relates to this historical
feminization and weakening that Republicans
have sort of successfully done the Democrats
when it comes to foreign policy because Hey,
Democrats don't want illegal Wars, never ending
Wars occupations in the wrong country that
didn't actually do all of that stuff they've
feminized. And may framed as weak Democrats.
But more importantly, they also liked to pretend
that a progressive president, like a Bernie
or a Warren would ignore the advice of experts.
If anything, the problem we have right now
is that Trump ignores advice from experts.
Bernie or Warren would actually listen to
what experts are saying, and we should be
glad for that. So Joseph, I don't know if
you're asking this question in good faith
or not, uh, but assuming that it's in good
faith, you appear to have been bamboozled
by some of the right wing talking points on
this issue that does it
for today. We've got a great bonus show coming
up for you today. Become a member or a patron
to get instant access. Go to join pacman.com
right now. Takes under one minute. Sign up
the David Pakman show@davidpakman.com [inaudible].